de retour en direct avec marc lavergne
chercheur au cnrs spécialiste du soudan
et de la corne de l'afrique pour parler
de la situation du côté de l'ethiopie et
de la région du tigré puisque on le
rappelle le chef de l'état français
emmanuel macron s'est entretenu hier
avec les deux chefs de gouvernement
soudanais éthiopien marc lavergne
pourquoi paris s'intéresse à cette
région de la corne de l'afrique
en quoi le tigre et est-il stratégique
ajouté
en tout cas l'afrique est un sujet
d'intérêt de préoccupation pour la
france ça on le voit avec une présence
de monsieur mac ont récemment au tchad
et est donc toute l'évolution du système
de barkan pour ce qui est du sahel alors
pour ce qui est du soudan
la france était vraiment mises en avant
pour soutenir le premier ministre actuel
abdallah noc
donc la france à alp en tête des pays
occidentaux pour levée des sanctions qui
ont été faits par les américains mais
aussi pour apporter de l'argent au
soudan et les poppys récents compris
dans ce cadre c'est à dire que le faisan
demain compte rendu en ethiopie ya déjà
deux ans je crois il a fait un bref
séjour là bas
maintenant il veut aussi soutenir cette
expérience démocratique et cette
expérience de pacification de la corne
de l'afrique qui importe à la france
parce qu'on a une base militaire à
djibouti
bien entendu qui est importante d'un
point de vue géostratégique pour tous
les indiens les rouges et aussi je pense
que l'ethiopie c'est c'est le siège de
l'union africaine à addis abeba c'est le
seul pays d'afrique il n'a pas été
colonisés c'est un pays de 110 millions
d'habitants qui est engagé sur la voie
du développement
donc je pense que la france considère
qu' il ya là un enjeu géostratégique
important non seulement pour la france
mais pour les pays occidentaux et donc
monsieur mac ont agi en tant que
représentant de la république française
mais aussi peut-être de l'union
européenne pour essayer de conforter les
initiatives qui peuvent se dérouler
aujourd'hui c'est de ramener la
stabilité à l'intérieur du pays qu'est
ce qu'on peut
réellement espérer dans cette
intervention est ce qu'on peut espérer
également peut-être une trêve dans cette
région dans quelle mesure un dialogue
politique peut-il s'ouvrir entre les
parties prenantes
je crois que c'est extrêmement difficile
à 7
cet appel à la responsabilité je dirais
des dirigeants c'est quelque chose qui
ne ne pèsera pas lourd dans l'enjeu
actuel parce que monsieur a dit à m le
premier ministre éthiopien n'a plus la
main il a joué un coup de poker je
dirais en allant au tigré pour essayer
d'éliminer la force armée et le pouvoir
du tplf que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
dans le sujet il n'a pas réussi parce
qu'il a mal mesuré la puissance
militaire du tplf et son soutien dans la
population
et aujourd'hui il est vrai se déliter
l'ensemble de l'ethiopie tant que les
combats qui se déroulent actuellement
sont pas seulement aux tigres et où
l'armée s'est deja halle est impuissante
il faut le dire mais aussi aujourd'hui
entre les afars et les somalis deux
autres régions qui s'embrase sur la
route qui relie la capitale addis abeba
à djibouti c'est à dire le cordon
ombilical de la capitale qui risque
aujourd'hui d'être coupé de tout ce sera
l'une times en eau nourriture en
attendant voix à côte et relie l'île
maurice ailleurs justement marc lavoine
envoie à côté de vous un des images de
l'acheminement de cette aide humanitaire
croyait des restrictions dans cet
acheminement on parle de route peut être
entravé par des problèmes de sécurité
après l'attaqué d'un convoi du programme
alimentaire mondial le 18 juillet
dernier
rapidement un gris ont dû fermer parce
que l'alarmé dieu pied mais remonter
directement vers le nord pour se
confronter aux sources du tipi élèves
est en réalité le combat s'est déplacée
parce que le petit père est frappant
c'est que pour vraiment mettre à chez
nous le pouvoir central et le sait a dit
armel il fallait couper ce cordon
ombilical qu'est la route avec tous les
camions tous les couvre d'aidé
humanitaire n'est pas seulement tout le
ravitaillement quotidien de la capitale
plusieurs millions d'habitants inquiets
la capitale de l'afrique est bien dépend
de ce qu'on cordon
embellie call alors les coups bas les
vrais combats se déroulent hors du tigre
et le long de ces 4 et de pau en
particulier qui engendre des rivières et
tu maintenant il ya des conflits
ethniques qui se déclenche entre ces
deux voisins des afars et les à manico
chacun une région puisque l'ethiopie est
un état fédéral et c'est donc l'ensemble
de l'ethiopie qui risquent de se
démembrer parce que l'armée fédérale ne
peut pas être partout de la foi et donc
il ya des milices tribales qui se mettre
en place et qui sont extrêmement
dangereuses pour les populations civiles
merci marc lavergne pour votre analyse
rappelle que vous êtes directeur de
recherche au cnrs spécialiste du soudan
et de la corne de là